good morning John it's it's Black Friday
of course you know it's it's the day in
which all Americans keep their lights
off for one day and it's really
interesting to me that we all do this
but very few people actually know the
story of how Black Friday began let's go
back all the way to 1789 the first
Congress of the United States the first
acts of that Congress was to create
something called the lighthouse service
now lighthouses have of course prevented
the deaths of countless sailors over
millennia but they do need maintenance
right back at the day it was impossible
basically to tell the world that a
lighthouse was gonna be down for
maintenance which would occasionally
result in sailors being lured into a
false sense of security they thought
there would be a lighthouse there they
don't see the lighthouse and then dashed
upon the rocks and everybody dies this
was a real problem so in the mid-1800s
the lighthouse service decided to pick
one day a year in which all of the
lighthouses would go down for
maintenance and everyone would know that
that was lighthouse maintenance day
basically they picked the day after
Thanksgiving because they figured that
was something that everyone would
remember and also it's a day on which
there would be less commercial shipping
traffic but it didn't take too long
before people started conflating that
maintenance day with a kind of Day of
Remembrance for fallen sailors so in
port towns all across New England all of
the lights would get turned on one to
remind everyone that this was indeed the
day when you couldn't count on the
lighthouses
and two to remember all of the sailors
and fishermen who had been lost at sea
over several decades this tradition
spread down the coast and then
eventually across the entire United
States many people not really knowing
why they were turning their lights off
just knowing that it was sort of a nice
cozy thing to do on the day after
Thanksgiving and now here we are in 2017
and of course lighthouse maintenance is
done during the day so weirdly on Black
Friday lighthouses are one of the only
lights that actually gets turned off
that was my black forehead a story time
I made all of that up except for the
part about the lighthouse service being
one of the first things that was created
by the first Congress of the u.s. that's
a real thing Black Friday actually is
the day on which Christmas shopping
begins and so all companies are like no
we must have your dollars and so they
lower prices a lot and yeah we're doing
that wente percent off almost everything
at dftba.com things from your favorite
creators including us but also CGP grey
and Kurt's Cassatt and minutephysics
also Jenna that aren't educational but
also we were launched
a store for vihart today so vihart merch
for the first time ever is going on sale
today we've also got 500 signed copies
of turtles all the way down that we
snagged from penguin so most of those
are sold out in the real world but we
have some of the dftba warehouse and
were selling them along with the tuatara
pin and a turtle sticker pack and
there's a clearance page where things
are 50% off because we literally need to
like make room in the warehouse I
thought that that was always a made-up
thing that was like warehouse clearance
and no we need that there's not enough
space in the warehouse also we're doing
like a last sale of VidCon merch so if
you didn't get VidCon merch when you
were there you can get it now it's super
sale and we're not gonna have it anymore
speaking of VidCon there's a 10%
discount on all VidCon ticket types if
you put in the coupon code turkey tile
so for the project for awesome we
usually do a calendar and a t-shirt
during the project for awesome this year
we're doing that before the project for
awesome and this is the calendar it's
just a vlog where this calendar me and
Jon did a photo shoot in which we got
real silly and I mean oh my god I'm
really proud of this the theme is silly
brother serious brother I'm wearing that
shirt right now actually it's good and
all proceeds go to the foundation to
decrease worldsuck is also a very cool
shirt there are more things just
launched a new project called scishow
fines which is like cool things that you
can get for the sciency loving people in
your life basically it's just stuff that
I would like to get and finally every
year John and I do a census of
nerdfighteria it's a pretty long survey
it takes about 20 minutes to do it or if
you're really into it it helps us
understand this community who you are
what you want and to help us decide what
to do next thank you so much for doing
that and if you want to turn off all
your lights and get cozy this Black
Friday I suggest you do that it's
actually kind of sounds like a lovely
thing John I'll see you on Tuesday but
before you turn on the lights don't
forget go nerdfighteria census thank you
so much it is so helpful to people who
do that